the russian invasion of ukraine
continues and i want to get everybody up
to speed there before we move on to
other things and as always when we say
we have a report of something that's
what we mean we have a report of
something and we always are waiting for
hoping for confirmation of more details
and um just something important to keep
in mind when there are assertions made
in the fog of war
sometimes the truth ends up being
slightly different and that is certainly
what russia is hoping for because of an
absolutely disastrous headline
60 people killed after bomb hits school
vladimir zelinski the ukrainian
president says this is a bbc report
around 60 people were killed after a
bomb hit a school in east ukraine
says president zielenski
earlier the governor of the luhansk
region sir haidai
said 90 people had been sheltering in
the building and 30 were rescued mr
haidai said a russian plane dropped the
bomb on saturday russia has not
commented luhansk has seen fierce combat
as russian troops and separatist
fighters seek to surround government
forces much of the region has been under
the control of russia-backed separatists
for the past eight years now that detail
is much of what's being used to say
russia would never do this that's a
region their separatist fighters have
been in for so long but if we've learned
one thing in the last few weeks it's
even things that lots of people say
russia would never do
then russia does and though and so i
don't think we can go by that um at all
uh we also are
waiting sort of anxiously to figure out
what is it that might happen on russia's
so-called victory day today may 9th and
by the time that today's episode goes
live you may know more about this than
we we know right now an nbc news article
asks what does putin have planned on
russia's victory day experts say that
after two months of
thwarted offensives putin is left with
limited options from an all-out
mobilization
to simply declaring victory in the
eastern donbas region now that's an
interesting idea that's being brought up
which is we don't know putin's emotional
state
we don't know again increasingly more
and more reports about putin's ill
health we don't know whether he is sort
of in some kind of unhinged last
attempt at uh
reconstructing the soviet union in some
kind of idealized way we just don't know
what he is capable of and interested in
but one idea
that would be a face-saving idea absent
a victory so far when it comes to
ukraine at large
would be to say hey you know what we did
it in the sense that we've now
really solidified control of the eastern
donbass region
and even though we didn't take heave and
some other places further into ukraine
pointing west from russia
uh really this was the goal and we did
it and we won we took the donbass region
and of course it wouldn't be completely
true but it would at least be more true
than they took all of ukraine which
certainly russia has not done so that
would be a kind of face saving
way for putin maybe to start kind of
backing up but again we we just don't
know a few other interesting notes from
the article which says monday is shaping
up to be a pivotal day for ukraine
known as victory day in russia may 9th
is a national holiday commemorating the
soviet union's defeat of nazi germany in
world war ii typically marked by an
elaborate military parade in moscow's
red square
surveyed by senior kremlin officials a
little north korea-like yes for sure
western officials have voiced concerns
that putin will use the occasion to
officially declare war on ukraine which
russia invaded in february experts say
that after more than two months of
thwarted offensives putin is left with
limited options as i said an all-out
mobilization or simply declaring victory
in the eastern donbas region now on the
declare war thing we talked a little bit
about declare war last week during a
live stream as this article restates
putin spokesman dmitry peskov denied
that a war declaration was imminent
insisting the invasion remained a quote
special military operation that may be a
nominal difference as the article points
out since russia has mobilized air
ground and naval forces across vast
areas of ukraine but declaring war
would allow putin to call up additional
army reservists and more people and
could prolong this for uh certainly
months if not years so at the end of the
day
we don't know what is coming in the next
24 hours by the time today's episode is
out you may know more than i know right
now and we'll follow up on that tomorrow
but no matter what i mean in the best
case
where
putin says
we won in the sense that we got donbass
there are going to be hostilities
months or years for sure
and what this means for the people of
ukraine can't possibly be uh
particularly good so we're going to make
an effort this week to make sure we stay
on this story there have been so many
other things that have happened in the
last month
at the same time as there has been a
sort of
continued steady level of hostilities in
ukraine which often when things become
normalized like for example kids dying
of hunger
every day all over the world
it becomes less of a corporate news grab
because corporate news stories tend to
have a nice clean beginning beginning
middle and end and if we just remain in
the middle for a long time sort of like
happened with covid as i said happens
with hunger around the world it starts
to come out of the news and that's
something we're going to try to push
back against so last week after we
learned of the imminent overturning of
roe v wade by the supreme court thanks
thanks this leaked decision we still
don't know who leaked it and we'll talk
about that later one of the things i and
some others said
is they're not going to stop at just
abortion you don't stop after your
biggest victory arguably in decades you
say
what else can i get you've gotten an
inch so you try to take a mile really
you've gotten a mile so you try to take
10 miles and some of you wrote to me and
said david i just don't see it i was uh
confronted by some callers last week
saying david this isn't going to happen
and as i said last week i don't
literally believe that they're going to
try to ban interracial marriage any time
soon i mentioned a number of different
areas that they might focus
contraception
uh
gay marriage
um
all these other things and sure there
are people who are against abortion who
also happen to be against interracial
marriage we know that because we just
know about demographics and and
statistics in the united states and over
the weekend in just a two-day period we
are already seeing them push beyond this
in two different cases let's look at
each of these examples first and
foremost
jake tapper on cnn
interviewed mississippi governor tate
reeves which tate reeves and mississippi
are at the core of this anti-abortion
push mississippi passing one of the most
if not the most restrictive abortion
bill in the country which is now the
subject and the appeal matter for the
supreme court in the decision that will
likely overturn roe v wade and jake
tapper asked tate reeves okay well what
about banning plan b sometimes known as
the morning after pill what about
banning iuds these are intrauterine
devices it's a form of birth control
that is available uh to people if if
they prefer that over
the pill or whatever else are you going
to push for that
and tate reeves doesn't say no we're not
interested in that tate reeves very
coyly says we're not focused on that
right now which means we're leaving the
door open to do exactly that all we have
is a leaked draft we don't have a final
yeah no i agree
i agree on the matter but just to be
clear the state of mississippi you're
not going to then target iud or plan b
which are methods of birth control that
might not allow a fertilized egg to be
implanted and this is not a theoretical
construct this is not a you know in the
state of louisiana which i recognize is
a neighboring state not your state i
mean they're talking about uh not only
criminally charging uh girls and women
who get abortions uh as you know as as
being
committing homicide but they're also
talking about defining the moment
of conception as fertilization which
would theoretically if this were to
become the law of louisiana and it is
not yet
uh mean that murder if you use an iud
you are committing murder theoretically
so it's not i'm not making this up this
is these are the conversations going on
in legislatures in your in your area but
so just to be clear you have no
intention of seeking to ban iuds or plan
b
that is not what we're focused on at
this time we're we're focused on that is
not so the question was you have no plan
to ban these things and he says that is
not what we are focused on at this time
we know enough about how politicians
speak
uh that we can understand what that
means and then texas governor greg
abbott he's also reinvigorated and full
of energy for banning more things on the
the news of this roe v wade decision
forthcoming decision he says well listen
now that we we've gotten this roe v wade
thing we're going to look at challenging
a supreme court ruling as well which
protects the right to free public
education for every kid including kids
with undocumented parents right now if
you're a kid and your parents are
undocumented so the supreme court has
decided you still have access to public
schooling
supreme court decision
greg abbott says we're going to look at
overturning that know this and that is
texas already
long ago sue the federal government uh
about having to uh incur the cost of
that educational program which is a case
called tyler versus doe uh and the
supreme court ruled against us on the
issue about denying uh or let's say
texas having to bear that bird i think
we will resurrect that case uh and
challenge this issue again because the
expenses are extraordinary there it is i
mean they are invigorated and rightly so
plan b and iuds could be next in
mississippi
taking away schooling from the children
of undocumented immigrants is on the
agenda in texas and
they are rightly invigorated again this
i would if i were them
and i just got arguably one of the
biggest political victories in decades i
would be feeling pretty damn invigorated
as well and i'd be saying well what else
we can do where what else can we do
where else can we go with this and they
are going places interracial marriage
yeah maybe not
maybe not but these are areas they are
definitely going dangerous times we have
memorial day coming up on monday
memorial day may 30 we are going to be
running a blowout membership special
that is going to absolutely rock your
socks off
knock your socks off
wow smack your socks off i don't even
know i'm so fired up by it and it's
going to be fantastic alex jones is
furious about it oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to find themselves is
bad incredible if you want to take
advantage of this historic membership
discount to really get us ready for the
midterms
please sign up for my newsletter at
davidpakman.com and on monday memorial
day you'll get an email telling you how
to sign up
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
last week after the forthcoming roe v
wade decision from the supreme court
leaked there was immediately speculation
about who did the leaking now much of
the speculation was really in bad faith
it was right-wingers arguing that the
real problem here is that there was a
leak rather than the fact that women's
rights are going to be potentially set
back by decades thanks to a number of
activist judges placed on the supreme
court by failed former president donald
trump so the issue isn't actually the
leaker but the right wanted to make the
leak or the issue and the right
immediately said obviously this is a
left-wing leaker
who wants to pressure
justices to change their votes
to keep roe v wade by making them fear
for their lives and
you know followed from there and as i
said last week we don't know the
political orientation of the leaker
there are two at least equally plausible
explanations one is the leaker is on the
left the leaker is pro-choice and the
idea of the leaker was i'm gonna leak
this now
so that the justices planning to vote to
overturn roe v wade will be pressured
and they will be harassed and they might
fear for their lives and they'll say
okay okay i'll keep roe v wade
now
these are appointments for life supreme
court justices have great security
it's not super likely that that is
actually the case but it is a
possibility
just as likely is the opposite and again
we didn't know one way or the other but
just as likely is the hypothesis that
the leaker is right wing why would a
right winger leak the decision a right
winger would leak the decision
to
make sure
that by making the expected votes public
none of the justices that are at least
as of the february draft planning to
vote to overturn roe v wade change their
minds
imagine that i don't know
kavanaugh was on the overturn row side
back in february when the draft was
written but since is thinking you know
maybe i should maybe i should vote to
keep it
the idea would be a right winger leaks
it to put pressure on those justices not
to change their votes either one is
possible but now we are actually getting
more and more information that the right
wing leaker scenario is the more
probable one nina totenberg who is a
longtime supreme court reporter says
actually the main theory now is that
this was a right-wing clerk who leaked
this take a listen covering the court
since the early days of roe how much has
this leak rattled the institution and
and the way it's viewed
well the way it's viewed it's it's an
earthquake and i think within the court
itself it's an earthquake there has
never been a leak like this there have
been minor little springs that have
emerged from the court uh
reports of a
a tentative vote or misbehavior by one
justice back in the 50s 60s 70s
there were leaks those kinds of leaks
but never an entire draft of a majority
opinion that has never ever
occurred before and it can only
in all likelihood have come from a
justice that i think is less likely
perhaps one of the clerks and the
leading the leading theory is a
conservative clerk who was afraid that
one of the conservatives might be
persuaded by chief justice roberts and
to join a much more
uh moderate opinion
um and then there's another theory that
it was an outraged liberal clerk but i
think the only one that makes
sense is that it came from somebody
who was afraid that this majority might
not hold that chief justice roberts
might persuade one of the conservatives
to come over to him so this type of
reporting is increasingly pointing to a
right winger now we may never know but
remember ted cruz and others were saying
jail the leaker they were assuming it
was a liberal and they were saying you
gotta jail them ted cruz actually went
on fox news and said the leaker should
be jailed remember this reason it was
leaked
is some left-wing presumably law clerk
wanted to put political pressure on the
five justices that presumably are in the
majority right now they wanted to put
heat and they wanted to invoke politics
to try to get them to change their vote
and and by the way if if that left-wing
law clerk succeeds it will be the most
grotesque politicization of the supreme
court in the history of our nation you
mentioned an fbi investigation i hope
there is a serious one and i hope
whoever is responsible for this not only
is fired instantly but is prosecuted and
serves real jail time for violating the
confidences of the supreme court and
then the last real liberal by which i
mean a right-wing reactionary tool c
gabbard she went on tv and also said we
we've got to prosecute in jail but
what's the crime tool see she didn't say
to be heard
i think it's also critical to point out
that
this leak sets a very very dangerous
precedent for our supreme court for
three important reasons number one is
first of all this person is a thief who
stole this information released it with
a very specific intent to try to incite
protesters and intimidate and pressure
our supreme court justices to make a
political decision rather than a
decision that is based on the
constitution
number two we have the fact that
you know the supreme court is not in
place to legislate from the bench
people's representatives at the state
level at the federal level are charged
to make laws not the supreme court the
supreme court needs to make decisions uh
based on the constitution and the
department of justice lastly needs to go
and prosecute this
crime which is exactly what it is and
make an example out of the person who
leaked this information because our
supreme court justices cannot operate
under the fear that they will have
partisan political activists in their
house
intimidating and threatening their
ability to do their job per the
constitution and there was a
do they still want them jailed if it is
a right winger but more importantly will
we ever actually find out who did it i
don't know that we will the trump
rallies are becoming increasingly
politically relevant as they are now
regularly meant to support 2022
candidates now i was the first to tell
you last week trump got two wins uh jd
vance in ohio
as well as what was the other one now oh
j.r majewski in michigan who i
interviewed i should remember him trump
endorsed two people and they won but now
we have a new challenge which is dr
mehmet oz who is running for the senate
in pennsylvania trump has endorsed him a
lot of republicans don't like oz and the
most notable thing the most notable
thing about trump's rally in support of
dr oz over the weekend was not only that
the crowd sometimes booed dr oz but that
trump seemed visibly disoriented and his
speech was extremely confused now we've
gotten used to the glitches from trump
like you might remember when trump got
his own name wrong at a rally then he
went donald trump yeah donald trump when
trump got obama's name wrong at a rally
obama
when trump got the name of mexico wrong
at a rally mexico when trump got mitt
romney's name wrong at a rally a rhino
named mitt romney when trump got the
name of someone he endorsed wrong at a
rally we've endorsed jp right j.d mandel
when trump got the name of his own
social media platform wrong at a rally
truth essential okay so but here trump
actually seemed confused about ideas for
example in this first clip trump says
pennsylvania is where our founding
fathers
declared american energy independence
what what
pennsylvania is the commonwealth where
our founding fathers
declared american energy independence
think of that you were the first ones
many many many
years ago
i don't know what he's talking about
maybe he just means that philadelphia is
where independence was declared but
energy independence is not making a lot
of sense visibly disoriented seemed
almost punch drunk then at another
moment trump says that if dr oz wins
his wife will be the first lady of
pennsylvania but oz
oz is running for senate not for
governor
i could have has
i could have had a great out
[Applause]
i could have had and by the way your
wife is so incredible you're going to
get a great first lady
in the commonwealth of pennsylvania
you're going to get her first lady i
know her well she's incredible and and
does she love her family her husband and
her family yeah so anyway oz is running
for senate not i guess if it was the
governorship you might say the first
lady of pennsylvania but all very
strange at another point trump
seeming to
be kind of impressed in some way that
maybe
oz's tv show gets him girls i mean this
is just strange stuff known him a long
time his show is great he's in that
he's on that screen he's in the bedrooms
of all those women telling them good and
bad
and they love him he came into a place
where we had a lot of women sitting
there waiting for something unrelated
they started going crazy is that dr roz
that's dr ross yeah so trump seemingly
jealous i guess of uh the effect that
oz's show has on women now in all
seriousness
the entire rally was supposed to be for
oz
and there was actually quite a bit of
booing whenever his name would come up
it doesn't seem the trump crowd is
necessarily sold on oz
my friend dr mehmet oz he's a great man
and even a bunch of people interviewed
before the rally said that i am not sold
on oz here uh trump did an impression of
a rocket ship at one point we endorsed
jd and he was like a rocket ship he went
uh and then at another point he came
very close to calling mitch mcconnell a
pos which i i love quite frankly i think
the more that these people can fight
amongst themselves the better
mitch mcconnell is the least popular
politician
in the country according to the no he's
an old broken down
crow i want to be nice i don't want to
call
oh i wanted to have i had that word
right and i just want but i couldn't do
it
i'd go home and the first lady would say
why did you use that foul language
darling i love you so much but why did
you use it
he said all broken down piece of crow
[Applause]
yeah a piece of crow
um and then just some surreal
kafka-esque moments and at one point a
speaker brought up by trump referred to
him as jonald
donald trump president donald j trump to
thank for that he gave me three shout
outs i spoke it to the rallies i loved
the pledge it was really quite a cast of
characters um when mehmet oz spoke it
was pouring he was soaking wet and he
talked about keeping the borders clean
which i don't even know what that means
faith and we'll fight back are you
willing to fight china
we're going to fight for our kids in our
schools
are you going to fight back to keep our
borders clean you're going to fight back
yeah you got to keep those borders clean
maybe with like an injection almost of
bleach or something like that and then
maybe the most surreal moment dinesh
d'souza spoke he has like a new i can't
even call it a documentary because it's
all bs he has a new
he has a new uh
series of stitched together audio visual
bits i guess is what we can call it and
he has developed the term ballot
trafficking it's not a term i've heard
before he may be using the same random
word generator that trump uses
but here he is listen to this and paid
ballot trafficking
in some states it is legal
to give someone else your ballot and
have them drop it off
usually the conditions of that are kind
of specified they're clear in georgia
for example you can give your mallet to
a family member
or if you're in a confined facility you
can give it to a caregiver and as you
can see just an incredibly riveting
speaker the people on stage right behind
dinesh uh talking amongst themselves
many of them not even facing dinesh very
very strange stuff and lastly it's not a
trump rally until trump literally leaves
you stranded in the mud here is video of
with ymca playing listen to this
leaving in the mud trying to get around
barriers it's completely flooded trump
got the hell out of there and it is a
classic at these rallies uh horrible
conditions people getting stuck
sometimes for hours and just really a
display of the absolute worst worst
worst of american culture and politics
so the question will be
does oz win the primary with trump's
endorsement because this one doesn't
seem to be going quite as well as some
of the others we'll have these clips on
our instagram make sure you're following
us there at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show an extraordinarily disturbing story
broke over the weekend about the failed
former president donald trump and you
know one of the things i said was
it's going to take us a long time to
learn the full scope of the danger that
happened during those very dark four
years in american history
and we are learning something new almost
every single week the new report
is per donald trump's former secretary
of defense mark esper
trump wanted to bomb mexico
um you'd think well but david there must
be more yeah there's more but that's
basically the story trump wanted to send
missiles to mexico to attack the drug
cartels and then maybe just kind of like
say it wasn't us and pretend he didn't
do it and be like i don't know you know
maybe it was canada i don't really know
here is mark esper on 60 minutes last
night
telling this disturbing story
the president
pulls me aside on at least a couple
occasions and suggests that maybe
we have the u.s military shoot missiles
into mexico shoot missiles into mexico
for what he would say to to go after the
cartels and we would have this private
discussion where i'd say mr president
you know i i understand mr president sir
bad idea the motive because he was very
serious about dealing with drugs in
america i get that we we all understand
but i had to explain to him we can't do
that it would violate international law
it would be terrible for our neighbors
to the south it would you know impact us
in so many ways here's the reasons why
bombing mexico
uh
is a bad idea ace why don't we do this
instead you politely push back on the
idea
did president trump really say
no one would know it was us yes
yes i i i he said that and i just
thought let's paint the missiles the
color of the guatemalan flag and then
they'll say with this must have been
guatemala it's fanciful right because of
course it would be us i was reluctant to
tell this story
because i think i thought people won't
believe this that they'll think well so
he was reluctant to tell it until he
could make money from it at which point
he put it in a book and all of these
guys and gals do that they all do that
and that we've talked about before i'm
just making it up and folks in
in in trump's orbit we'll dispute it and
then i was having dinner after the
election in 2020 with a fellow cabinet
member
and and he said to me he goes you know
remember that time when president trump
suggested you shoot me
missiles into mexico
and i said to him you heard that he goes
oh yeah i couldn't believe it and i
couldn't believe how how well you
managed and talked him down from that
and at that moment i knew i got to write
the story because i at least have one
witness who will verify that this really
did happen now trump is not denying this
and we're going to get to that in a
little bit but think about this what in
a sense we're a super progressive
country right we elected the first
completely unqualified
dangerously psychopathically
narcissistic cognitively compromised
president now maybe we didn't but he's
pro there's prob there's been others
not in the united states um but this has
to be on the top 10 list of of wildest
ideas i mean we've got he wa he wanted
to nuke a hurricane
he wanted to inject bleach to kill covet
bombing mexico flushing presidential
records down the toilet eating
presidential records saying we're going
to get mexico to pay for a wall across
the entire southern border yeah what i
don't know exactly what else would be on
the top 10 list but this absolutely
would and just as we predicted every
week we learned the presidency was even
more dangerous than we ever knew at the
time and by the way
and this is where i want to go next
trump is not denying that he wanted to
bomb mexico which means he did want to
do it and that's what i want to discuss
with you next
so
trump former secretary of defense mark
esper
writes in his book
and goes on 60 minutes and says trump
wanted to bomb mexico and here's how i
talked him out of it and there's other
witnesses that heard that as well
well certainly trump is going to deny it
right
trump does not deny it which means he
did it donald trump in response to mark
esper's book
and the 60 minutes interview put out a
sort of q a a q a
um and we're going to look at it right
now and it is one of the most deranged
documents i've maybe ever seen from a
president it's a q a first question
during a june 1 2020 meeting at the
white house the cabinet was debating
what to do about protests and civil
unrest mark esper says president trump
wanted to shoot some of the protesters
in the legs a lot of foul language was
used and accused president trump of
calling members of the cabinet effing
losers trump trump's response
this is a complete lie and 10 witnesses
can back it up well who are they and can
we stop can we talk to them mark esper
was weak and totally ineffective and
because of it i had to run the military
i took out isis kasem solomoni al
baghdadi rebuilt the military with 2.5
trillion created space farce and so much
more mark esper was a stiff who was so
desperate not to lose his job he would
do anything i wanted that's why i called
him jesper he was a lightweight and
figurehead and i realized that early on
he was recommended to me by some very
weak rhinos and that is what he turned
out to be now
this is a typical trump lie like i don't
believe him as far as i can throw them
but more importantly
trump keeps having to go out and say
well bolton was a lightweight
esper was a lightweight tillerson was
right yeah all these people trump ran on
i'm gonna hire the best people and i'm
the best at picking folks and yet he was
snowed by rhinos and hired all the wrong
people that's weird next question to
trump
president trump wanted to send 10 000
active duty troops into dc after st
john's church was set on fire trump's
response wrong
i wanted to send at least 10 000 troops
for january 6th
because i knew people were coming to
protest the corrupt presidential
election pelosi and the dc mayor turned
me down
60 minutes should ask them why they
chose not to have proper security and
remember as we know on that day
all sorts of people including uh ivanka
were saying he's got to bring in the
national guard
and uh he didn't do that for hours
second a couple last questions here
later in a meeting at the white house
president trump contended that his
secretary of defense had taken away his
authority on the insurrection act and
didn't believe he could invoke it
anymore this is fake news the fact is i
didn't need to invoke the act and never
did
and lastly we can skip to the last
question on a couple of occasions
president trump suggested to esper they
quote attack the drug cartels with
missiles meaning bomb mexico trump's
response is no
comment
no comment
that means he did it that means he did
it and
you know
we're
it's almost beyond words
we are dealing with a complete and total
lunatic this guy would be
in a in a business where national
security isn't at stake you know running
a construction company
running a restaurant
running an accounting firm anywhere
people would say this person is
impossible to deal with he's completely
disconnected from reality
he is making it impossible for anybody
to do their jobs and it's bad
and that person has been put in charge
or was put in charge of running the
entire country a complete and total
dangerous narcissistic
lunatic and we continue to learn more
every single week one other thing that i
want to go back to here
if everybody that he hired ended up
being they were losers they were idiots
they're lying they're rhino traitors you
know uh pence did the wrong stuff he
didn't overturn the election and william
barr wasn't willing to
take legal action trump wanted him to
take on the election and esper was just
a
yes man and then uh
you know mark milley was a woke general
and bolton is a loser on and on and on
what does it say about trump's judgment
that he continually appointed these
so-called losers to the highest offices
in the land
to do some of the most important
functions that a president needs to
appoint people to do
it doesn't speak particularly well to i
will work with only the best people it
is bonkers it is absolutely bonkers
we're going to take a quick break and be
back right after this stay with us
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right so i got tricked by a trumpus
then i'm going to tell you about it and
um i think this is really instructive
and and informative so
last week when we were taking live calls
on the friday show i got a call from a
guy who says i used to be a moderator
for the donald the donald that's the
underscore donald was one of the most
toxic
pro-trump subreddits on the website
reddit um until it got banned the entire
thing was banned for just constant
disinformation and violating you know
all sorts of terms of service of reddit
and uh during that call this trumpist
moderator said to me hey david you know
now
they are promoting the use of
misoprostol
for abortions and it's just as unproven
as ivermectin so isn't there a double
standard on social media and here's
exactly what he said and how i responded
to it let's go next to uh let's go to
rich from illinois rich welcome
hi david hello
um so i was the top mod of donald on
reddit for years until just before it
was banned
and with elon buying twitter do you
think that there will be a general shift
in policy
for the uh the tech places
towards allowing things
like medical misinformation such as
ivermectin and what
vice's motherboard did yesterday with uh
tweeting out the misoprostol for
abortion pills
i what i didn't see the what's the vice
thing tell me about that
yeah so they uh tweeted out from their
motherboard account that micelle postal
which is a horse medicine
uh to treat ulcers for horses
can be used for
abortion pills oh i see that now yeah
uh okay so let's go step by step first i
uh i actually discussed this with
coleman hughes in an already recorded
but not yet released podcast episode
with him i actually don't think that
elon musk taking over twitter if it
happens remember it's still not been
approved and i think it may not be but
we'll wait and see
i don't think it's going to do anything
mind-blowing on on twitter per se i
think maybe some people will be unbanned
maybe not i don't know that he is widely
going to be involved in content
moderation so
i'm kind of i'm not making any big
judgments about what's going to change
on twitter let's first wait and see if
the the buyout actually happens and then
we'll kind of think about that part
um in terms of uh i mean listen i don't
know much about this misoprostol thing
but
i i also don't know whether this is an
approved off-label use or not i don't
know anything about it but let me just
say right now
all of this stuff should be subject to
the same scrutiny whether it's being
promoted by left or right i i think it
all should be subjected to the exact
same terms of service
okay
that's good so i responded in principle
because i didn't know anything about
misoprostol i just hadn't heard it i
hadn't heard about it up until this
point and uh i said well
if the circumstances are the same if
misoprostol is really to abortion
what uh ivermectin is to covet
if they really are equivalent then it
should be handled the same by social
media but it turns out that the trumpist
either lied to me
or just was ignorant himself because a
bunch of doctors and pharmacists emailed
me and said david you got tricked there
is no similarity between ivermectin and
misoprostol let's look at some of these
emails that i got here's the first one
i'm a medical doctor family medicine as
part of my job i delivered babies for
seven years i just watched your
interview with the ex the donald
moderator
misoprostol more commonly called cytotec
in the u.s isn't extremely commonly used
drugs in humans we use it to help induce
labor
and can be used to cause an abortion in
the first trimester by dilating the
cervix and allowing the product of
conception to fall out i've never
performed an abortion so my knowledge
based on that is limited but i've used
cytotec to induce labor hundreds of
times to compare it to ivermectin is a
mistake that's one medical doctor
another medical doctor wrote in hi david
huge fan listening to the friday collins
wanted to share that misoprostol is
indeed approved for human use has the
u.s brand named
cyrotec so it's either cytotec or
cyrotec there's the disagreement on that
but clearly we're talking about the same
medication used by ob gyns for inducing
miscarriage slash abortion used to help
women pass a partial miscarriage used to
induce labor during the third trimester
and also used for prevention of nsaid
induced ulcers his idea that it's a
horse medicine and not a human one is
not true
it is used for both as is ivermectin i
am an internal medicine physician so i
don't personally use it often an
obstetrician could provide more details
about when and how they use it i have
prescribed it to patients for ulcer
prevention that's dr isaac and then a
pharmacist wrote in who said you
recently took a call from a former the
donald moderator who mischaracterizes
misoprostol as a horse medicine to treat
ulcer for horses and not approved for
humans in an attempt to liken its
promotion to that of ivermectin for the
treatment of covid misoprostol is both
fda approved for human use
and indicated as an abortion drug and
has been proven to be both safe and
efficacious for this indication the same
can't be said for ivermectin in the
treatment of covid while i can't in good
consciousness recommend or promote
people taking a prescription strength
drug absent supervision of a licensed
medical professional this equivalency is
patently false and misleading that's
kyle the pharmacist so listen
you tricked me the donald moderator
maybe i mean maybe the guy knew that it
was a false equivalency
but um uh you know the the important
things here is okay
ivermectin
sometimes used in horses sometimes used
in humans
misoprostol sometimes used in animals
sometimes used in humans ivermectin
not okay to use for covid based on
randomized controlled trials misoprostol
regularly used as an abortion drug in
humans so
not the same thing and uh
this is why you know
i said and this is why we should never
go beyond what we know
and so when the ivermectin people
started with the ivermectin stuff
it wouldn't have been right for me to
say
it doesn't work for covid it will never
be shown to work for covid
maybe it does and it hasn't been shown
yet maybe someday it will be shown to
work for covid what i knew at the time
was we don't have any good science right
now that says ivermectin works for covin
and so let's be
thoughtful
when we make claim that it's actually
not going further than what we know at
the time
on the other hand when it comes to
something like misoprostol which i knew
nothing about
i responded and said i don't know a
thing about that in particular
if the circumstances are the same
as
ivermectin then it should be handled in
the same way by social media companies
it turned out later it is not at all the
same thing so hopefully an instructive
moment for all of us i want to play a
clip for you of former trump national
security adviser michael flynn
he believes
or at least claims to believe
that 5g
mobile phone technology mobile data
technology is going to sort of trigger
or flip a switch in a pathogen that was
injected into our bodies
through the covet vaccine
i know that's crazy it's completely nuts
let's listen to the clip this is a clip
from what is this from this is uh real
america's no real is this real america's
voice this is reawaken america
presented by american faith and clay
clark is interviewing michael flynn
and i dare you to follow this and make
sense of it i dare you to understand
what the hell they're talking about
check this out and now
it has become common knowledge that the
lipid nanoparticles found inside the
cova-19 vaccine can
carry pathogens
that can be activated uh with the right
frequency being sent to them so okay so
if so far what's being asserted i think
is
lipid nanoparticles in the vaccine
get injected
and then if they are subjected to the
right frequency so could be a radio wave
could be uv light or could be 5g
then they become activated
okay let's continue
there's a terrifying time to be an
american
uh sir how do you process this and what
what would you encourage our listeners
to do today sir
well i mean number one because this this
pathogen that you just talked about
i think that then there's some great
articles written about how it relates
[Music]
technology that is being
uh in input basically globally but i
statement is that uh because this is a
good versus versus evil time it is
actually one of the most consequential
periods in history to be alive but
they're talking out loud that lipid nano
particles in the shots contain pathogens
preparing for that here we go backing it
up here we go here we go
we know that marburg is not particularly
contagious but it has extraordinarily
high rate of fatality now for people who
don't know about marburg this is
to take a break from the insanity
um
ebola
is part of a group of viruses called
i believe the term is filo viruses
and filo i think the root means string
in latin and the the reason that they
call ebola and marburg filo viruses is
because under a micro microscope they
sort of look like strings
if you're interested in learning about
the history of ebola and marburg i can
highly recommend the non-fiction book
the hot zone very very interesting book
marburg is a real thing it's it's a cons
it's related to ebola um but these
people don't know what the hell they're
talking about
and we know the mechanism by which this
will be released and that is
inside of these shots that people
already received inside the lipid
nanoparticles the hydrogel there exists
pathogens inside of the particles that
have not yet opened those pathogens are
chimeric they include e coli marburg
ebola staphylococcus and brewers yeast
amongst others yeah brewers use
my i am actually worried because there's
yeast in there
uh i'm worried that my forearm is gonna
turn into a beautiful pumpernickel and
i'll have no choice to put pastrami and
mustard on it and it's going to be
horrible we know that upon the broadcast
from the 5g system that is now employed
across the united states in the world
for that matter um when they broadcast
an 18 gigahertz signal for one minute
three different times so you guys heard
that right it's
three pulses
at 18 gigahertz
within a minute that's the that's the
the the it's almost like a morse code as
a pulse it will cause those lipid
nanoparticles to swell and release these
pathogenic contents thereby causing a
marburg epidemic oh so it's marburg
that's in my arm jesus already spent the
money on they've already it's already
done right the marburg epidemic for
purposes of the law has happened and now
we just need the actual uh disaster to
happen and there's actually worse parts
to it than that including the 1v36 gene
deletion yeah the what this isn't even
the worst part of it those nano
particles must have some amazing
batteries because my phone won't even
last two days if i don't charge it and
somehow these particles have been
dormant from the vaccine i got a year
ago and they're ready to be activated by
5g the logical conclusion of course
is that donald trump is also going to
become a sort of marburg zombie right
because tr why would trump do that to
himself he made the vaccines and gave
them to himself to then be turned into a
5g marburg zombie
this is really crazy stuff
and does michael flynn believe it or has
he been pulled into some kind of vortex
where he's just around crazy people and
he has to go with it i don't know
and this goes from the same this is
along the lines of the vaccines will
magnetize you but that almost seems so
quaint compared to this that the
vaccines will magnetize you is almost
not crazy enough compared to the stuff
that they've uh that that they've come
up with so
strange times that we live in for sure
and i have to admit since i got boosted
the crema on my espresso machine when i
pull a shot
it is better i have to tell you it is
better and uh i don't know if the two
are related or not but very very crazy
stuff we have a voicemail number and
that number is 219 to david p i recently
appeared on a program called
trigonometry
where i went two on one
with some right wing wing british hosts
and at a certain point during that they
brought up the question of the
definition of a woman one of our viewers
didn't like that it was me and two other
dudes sitting around talking about the
definition of a woman listen to what she
had to say
david is susan from chicago i'm not
happy with you right now i just watched
a video or part of video of you with two
other guys sitting around discussing
what is a woman
what's wrong with you today
well in what world does that make sense
i mean seriously dude i like you every
day and i'm just watching this and i'm
my mind is blown
do it at what you will peace out bye
listen
i'm just i can't help that i am male
okay and i can't help that i was invited
onto a show
that show has two male hosts
and then they brought up the topic of a
definition of a woman so i i i don't
think it's the same as when we say hey
here's a panel of exclusively
70 year old white men deciding what the
rules on abortion should be from a
legislative standpoint i'm i'm with you
there that where are the women's voices
what it doesn't make any sense i was
just on a show and the topic came up
okay so let's take it easy let's not go
uh let's not go crazy here we have such
a great bonus show for you today number
one big oil
is cashing in and we're going to talk
about surging big oil profits where they
come from it's not as simple as the
price of oil is up and so they make more
money
it's actually more complicated than that
and we'll talk about that on today's
bonus show secondly the taliban which
some on the left and right like to say
is a much more moderate
influence within islam
is now ordering women to be covered head
to toe in public at all times period so
not exactly the progressive
uh inflows
uh that some were hoping for from uh the
taliban and then lastly
it it's insane that this is actually
becoming an issue but it is
the death penalty
for those who get abortions
is becoming a major issue in a
republican runoff in the state of texas
i've mentioned this once before
i think it was a few weeks ago and it's
growing as an issue and we're going to
talk about it on today's bonus show get
access to the bonus show so easily by
signing up at
joinpackman.com oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to find themselves is
bad yeah alex jones does not like the
bonus show he finds it predatory that is
a freaking predator right there i love
the bonus show and many of our members
around the world do so i encourage you
to sign up at joinpacman.com and then
lastly remember if you're absolutely not
willing to sign up today
monday may 30 memorial day it's a lot of
a lot of m's
we're doing a one-day
insane membership blowout the reason i'm
doing it on a federal holiday is if my
accountant knew about this he would
never let me do it
if my lawyer knew about this he would
drop me as a client
we are doing a massive membership
blowout on may 30th i expect to run out
of memberships and if you want to be
notified about that you can get on my
mailing list at joinpacman.uh
i'm sorry no at davidpakman.com
davidpakman.com
get on the mailing list
get the bonus show
i will see you then or otherwise we will
be back here and together again tomorrow